isabelle sarah chéri non vous voulez
vraiment je vous réponde oui mais
malaisie et ben écoutez heureusement que
youssef faut lâcher un peu hein mais
après je passe toute l'aisne pas toute
la nuit avec lui j'ai aussi rabat
écoutez je le connais un peu youssef ce
sera pas toute la nuit un stade mais
mais c'est un de très bonnes amies c'est
un de mes meilleurs amis
ainsi alors isabelle vous allez monter
très haut
d'accord d'aller monter très long et
vous allez devoir vous lancer et être au
plus près du vide plus vous serez
pleurer du vide que vous ferez gagner un
magnifique cadeau un téléspectateur
puisque si vous atteignez le dernier
très vous gagnerez une mini moto
d'accord vous fera gagner une mini moto
aux oreilles deux essais isabelle je
vous rappelle que vous détestez l'eau et
ce soir exceptionnellement pour cette
appli hng il n'y aura pas une goutte
d'eau pour vous oui bien sûr la jolie va
regarder bas dans le vide on va pas
rajouter de l'eau à part s'il pleut
d'accord vous allez monter niveau retour
loup oui bah non non non vous n'allez
pas arrêter avec ça c'est bon j'en ai
assez là toujours de suggérer vial vous
savez je te dernier isabelle mais
attention il a belle sandra ça brise à
metz prend de la hauteur 1
merci garder les vauriens votre mur en
tout cas la tension isabelle et moi et
rien que ça déjà c'est grâce au vent et
la neige
moi j'ai peur du vide c'est pour ça que
je regarde jamais mon cerveau et c'est
fou non plus hein pas réchauffer la lcf
à la foire coûte réchauffer la xf
isabelle inventé on va me lâcher
mais on va se placer isa au nom à 30
mètres du sol isabelle isabelle vous
attirer comme un habit cydia est là
parce qu'il ya eu ces petits bourgs et
chose ça fait rire tout le monde
isabelle vous êtes à 30 mètres du sol un
grande attention
isabelle ressortez vos ça y est on est
posée à 30 mètres du sol usa où c'est
cela va vous décembre
bravooo descente h attention il va vous
allez devoir vous jeter au plus près du
mur sont tout près du vide jabel pour
gagner et pour faire gagner cette mini
moto après les prêteurs l'impressionnant
ryan au téléphone ça dure ryan comment
ça va merci ryan salut merci le jour on
arrivera à faire un affaire téléphonie
aller s'il vous plaît toutes les
précautions sont prises isabelle et
qu'elle se passera rien nous servait
scoop année isabelle s'il vous plaît
rapidement allez on ira rapidement
petitjean qui toi bah oui allez c'est
parti
merci youssef si tu pouvais pas nier le
cul bardot patron merci les verts de la
hauteur j'adore je suis pas du tout
cette fois il faut savoir c'est le mec
le plus gentil du monde au yoyo allez
allez isabelle isabelle est ce que vous
avez le vertige doucement d'un sérieux
est-ce que vous avez le vertige isabelle
tu veux je n'en sais rien à les guider
là vous allez au niveau 7 à 30 mètres du
sol isa je tenais ne vous inquiétez pas
vous jouez pour faire gagner une
magnifique mini moto avec ryan d'accord
is a way
il s'en est ce que vous êtes content de
faire gagner la mini-moto et tu vas
match de répondre oui mais alors ouais
ouais
isabelle on va vous allez on va vous
installer sur une luge à 30 mètres du
sol isabelle vous allez vous lancer et
essayer d'aller au plus près du mur que
ça donne tu te tais toi
isabelle c'est bon et à plouay est pas
plus loin pour vous mettre la luge il ya
une remplaçant à m on peut savoir
je vais tomber les talons aller à tokyo
tiens tu tiendras en plein allez dans
quelques mois je suis là vous lui
enlevez les talons isa vous allez
essayer d'aller au plus près du qui peut
l'enlever sans défaire au pardon à les
peindre avec ses dents à merde [ __ ] je
viens de perdre 2 cm la bête inquiète
pas s'affermit l'ostéoporose omh la jda
raconte isabelle c'est un grand moment
pour nous isabelle vous êtes accros de
fait le seul vous jouez pour nous tous a
laissé baule où il s'agit en revanche
installe izard la troisième place et
voilà maintenant plus
commences à te mettre à genoux alors à
me mettre dans ma poche de tomates on
joue la voix leur poste au genou l'autre
passion de l'autre voilà là c'est trop
c'est trop
isabelle voilà ta valise à attendre
notamment on est ce que tu peux le faire
risa c'est le match que talons manon est
allongé 30 n'a pu talons hauts c'est bon
je remercie c'est bon j'ai pas beaucoup
mieux la torche cul ça la change de
kraft les abeilles qui ont voulu annuler
mais non c'est pas nul et trou du cul
c'est abel est ce qu'on est prêt est ce
qu'un des leurs la tranchée ban est sauf
et non je suis pas prête en plus
pointues 110 pieds là je l'adoré soyaux
les jeunes adorent 90 at elle soutient
les à isabelle de l'année et là je peux
te dire un truc ma chérie ouais je
t'aime et tu veux t'en dit notre truc
oui bah écoute adapté en descendant fait
elle dit toujours le même temps au
soleil on croit qu'on va dire adios mon
plan b si loots f secure c'est de
réussir il sait secure où nous savons
allez-y doucement allégée du sport dans
ta tête tu fan de rasta rocket et michel
à aller vers la machine en route
takofanes fut sa compagne non c'est
petit ça est bien accroché ou pas il
arrive oui bien sûr et j'attends j'ai
l'impression que j'ai basculé en avant
ne tienne je reste toujours la main sur
l'or je vais lancer le linge maintenant
on va toujours rester près du fg panna
cotta dimanche matin faut pas tout ça
moi t'as pas la cote à six mois je vois
tu as ta kate paiz à qu'est ce que tu me
dis et isabelle josette ultra rien y'a
un airbag d'accord attention c'est parti
takofanes jeta coupe à aller 1-2 à les
appels
[Applaudissements]
les genres